all right welcome to Hannity We Begin
tonight with a Fox News Alert and we are
back with our live audience right here
in New York City the only people that
are normal in New York
in just a moment Mayhem in the windy
city shootings murder assault Anarchy in
the streets of our entire country almost
a great American city is dying literally
right before our eyes it is not the only
city now on the verge of Destruction
shocking video Straight Ahead plus
coming up house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
will join us with details surrounding
the nightmare that is Joe Biden at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue 8 57 a.m they called
the lid on the day Joe was done he was
tired he just got back from vacation he
had to visit castles anyway today marks
the 100th day that Kevin McCarthy has
been speaker we go we will remind you of
the promises he made to become speaker
and we will tell you the promises he has
kept we are going to hold elected
officials accountable plus we will talk
to the great one any Mark Levin fans
here
about the Biden family business it was
not just Hunters who turns a profit by
selling access to Pops and giving half
his income to Pops we have new
developments tonight that are huge we'll
break that news also Jimmy phela Kaylee
mcinany that will be here in studio with
more on the Panic the full-blown panic
at Budweiser and Anheuser-Busch as sales
now plummet even further we'll have full
analysis by the way of Tucker's
interview with Elon Musk listen to this
shocking revelation
the degree to which various government
agencies had effectively had full access
to everything that was going on on
Twitter blew my mind they have full
access even your direct messages private
messages between you and somebody else
Texas Senator Ted Cruz will weigh in
straight ahead but first we begin with
this top story tonight in New York City
explosive hearings revealing the ugly
truth about house Democrats they do not
care about you the American people and
your life now today Jim Jordan who is
the house Judiciary Committee chairman
paid a visit to the city to hear from
real victims of serious crimes families
that lost loved ones and for good reason
because while D.A Alvin Bragg is
spending you know what massive amounts
of money time resources uh going after
one man one organization one family the
Trump family 34 counts of nothing no
specific crimes barely mentioned but
actually violent offenders they are
roaming the streets with victims and
their families being treated like
garbage watch this
my son Sergeant Hassan Korea Afghanistan
war retired veteran was killed in Harlem
in 2018. Hassan was kick punched stocked
and stabbed nine times by four
individuals he did not know nor had he
done them any harm
when Alvin Brad came into office he was
held he was handed a strong trial-ready
murder case and gang assault case
against all four of these individuals
where this brutal Savage
homicide was captured on video
he was handed a strong trial-ready case
ready to go to trial as soon as he took
office the case immediately began to
unravel
and as far as the Manhattan District
Attorney's office if he's receiving one
penny a federal dollars you need to pull
that funding until he starts doing his
damn job and Prosecuting crime
I was totally disrespected me my family
my grandchildren we were treated like
garbage
like garbage
wow Madeleine brain will join us right
here in the studio in just a moment now
her son was an Army vet Hassan Korea was
his name was stabbed to death on the
streets of New York City his father also
seriously wounded during the attack
continues to deal with life-altering
injuries now according to a statement
from Bragg's office none of the four
perpetrators received the maximum
sentence not one of the four Mary
Saunders gets one year in jail already
out of prison Travis Stewart received
just seven years the other two felons
could be out in far less than 20 years
after murdering somebody with a knife
and nearly killing yet another person
you proud of that album brag now of
course New York City Congressman Jerry
Nadler the dope that he is just doesn't
seem to care take a look
Ms Graham you uh failed to note that as
a result of D.A Bragg's prosecution two
men are currently serving life sentences
for the murder of your son
Mr Jordan I'm sorry if Mr Nadler is
going to make derogatory comments
towards the mother of a homicide victim
he could at least allow her some time to
respond Hassan Korea is Dead Forever
Dead Forever
they're poor people
directly responsible for his murder
two people
is not Justice
now this is not uncommon under Bragg 52
percent of all felony cases they are
reduced to misdemeanors and predictably
violent crime is on the rise look at
this on your screen robbery up five
percent felony assault 15 burglary up
seven percent car theft up another five
percent the murder rate is still higher
than pre-pandemic levels but the
Democrats at today's hearing they didn't
want to talk about any of that instead
can you guess what they were obsessed
with they want to talk about Donald
Trump
I right there high in their Ivory Towers
these Democrats treated today's
Witnesses and these victims like
inconvenient deplorables the way these
Democrats behave was grotesque and
unhinged Congressman Hank Johnson even
referring to the victims people that
lost their loved ones as props for Jack
booted thugs in the Republican party you
think I'm making it up I'm not take a
look
like Jack booted thugs they've descended
on New York City using violent crime as
their pretext
the mega Republican extremists are not
interested in gun violence or even knife
violence
the Republican Witnesses who have used
their time to criticize district
attorney Brad
has served as props in a Maga Broadway
production the pompous indignation from
Democrats was so outrageous that some
New Yorkers in the crowd they had had
enough take a look
it is the GOP leadership in congress
doing what it has done best for the last
six years and that is to act as the
criminal defense Council for Donald J
Trump well let me tell you this let me
tell you this
Capitol Police General will suspend
Capital police
Capitol Police will remove the gentleman
from the audience let me tell you this
let me tell you this gentlemen
let me tell you this
there's probably
one of the biggest jackasses in all of
Washington DC and that's saying a lot
these Democrats don't care about Justice
they don't care about safety security
your Pursuit of Happiness they only care
about politics hating Donald Trump what
does Donald Trump have to do with safety
security in New York on Prosecuting
criminals nothing here's our very own
Sarah Carter take a look it seemed very
highly politicized as far as the dams
what was going through your mind during
the hearing yeah our Democratic
colleagues uh they're the ones who
wanted to politicize this hearing uh in
fact one of my colleagues pointed out
that not one of us had ever mentioned
mentioned former president Trump's name
it was all my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle I asked some of the
Witnesses in question who are actually
frankly getting kind of emotional and
upset the Democrats were ignoring their
pleas to listen to them about how unsafe
they feel in this city the fact that
they've lost loved ones or Mr Alba who
is simply defending himself got stabbed
and then was getting prosecuted by this
district attorney these are not
political statements these are just
telling their personal stories and to a
person all of the witnesses testimony
talk to about these heinous crimes
committed against their family members
losing their loved ones burying their
son and what did the Democrats do they
smeared them they said it was a circus
they belittled these Witnesses they said
it was a sham House Republicans focused
our questions on crime and focused our
questions on the fact that radical
district attorney Alvin Bragg is
refusing to prosecute these crimes let
me be clear Donald Trump doesn't prevent
crime has nothing to do with the Safety
and Security of the people in New York
he doesn't even live here it doesn't
make our country safer or a better place
so let's be clear the left their defund
dismantled no bail laws they are making
law-abiding Americans less safe less
secure it's a more dangerous environment
and if you don't have law order safety
security you cannot pursue happiness
take a look at your screen this was
Chicago over the weekend typical weekend
in Chicago hundreds of teens storming
the streets in downtown Chicago breaking
Windows Plus talking traffic jumping up
and down on cars attacking drivers and
elsewhere in the windy city 35 people
shot this weekend eight murdered and
almost no one arrested by the way nobody
in the media if they can't politicize it
they never talk about it we've been
scrolling names of people shot shot and
killed in Chicago on this program since
2009 names you've never heard of never
we will hear for about because they
can't politicize it a violent brawl at
the White Sox game what a great place to
have the Democratic Convention perfect
fit in 2024 and meanwhile this was a
scene out in California where a huge mob
ransacking a gas station near Compton
organized theft shoplifting looting
costing businesses 100 billion dollars a
year is it any wonder that major
companies they are packing up closing
down leaving town the American people
are also fleeing blue states and cities
in droves California New York they're
losing around 300 000 people a year
they're saying bye bye and they're
moving to free states like Texas Florida
Tennessee and the Carolinas and by the
way Florida gave more than what they're
gaining like 400 000 people a year now
between 2020 and 2022 a whopping 2
million uh people left major American
cities high taxes crime bad schools a
judicial system that favors criminals
over victims blue States blue cities
they are broken Americans are now voting
with their feet hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else